abenteuer alben wird ihnen präsentiert
von leo p
der geschmack der schweiz seit 11 115
[Musik]
grüße es ist sechs uhr morgens wieder
ein stück voller vereister spuren
ein sturz kann hier fatale folgen haben
ein seil soll's richten der vereiste
steilhang ist zu gefährlich um ihn ohne
sicherung zu befahren
der 72 jährige paul zeller macht den
anfang
wenn der tunnel nach ober weitere klasse
biete kamen giezendanner die
kaufmännische angestellte folgt
[Musik]
die ehemalige weltcup arien fränzi
aufdenblatten befürchtet dass sich die
bindung durch einen schlag öffnen
könnten
und wählt auch das sichere sein
einzig olympiasiegerin dominique gisin
wagten part
[Musik]
ist der krone durch so hätten zwar zeit
bis zur bahre verzeichnet noch ich
stelle
[Applaus]
seit drei tagen ist die
zusammengewürfelte gruppe unterwegs auf
der obhut von chamonix nach zermatt ein
pensionär ein heilpädagoge eine
kaufmännische angestellte ehemalige
skirennfahrerinnen ein ceo und eine
haushalts leeren wagen gemeinsam das
abenteuer in den alpen die dritte etappe
führt sie von der kabarett trio auf den
goldener grund louis eine lange abfahrt
bis hinunter ins tal nach la folie dann
mit bus nach wp und mit der bahn wieder
hoch zeit gab an man von 600 meter
aufstieg und 1700 meter abfahrt sind
heute zu bewältigen
dass die vereisten spuren tücken und die
skibindung nicht so stabil sind wie bei
pisten schießt bekommt dominique gisin
etwas später zu spüren
[Musik]
skitouren leiterin orlanda hilft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
manchmal ist es an der zeit aus dem
alltag auszubrechen sich für das zeit zu
nehmen wovon man geträumt und im leben
ein neues kapitel hinzuzufügen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
80 kilometer 7000 höhenmeter auf über
3000 metern über meer in sechs tagen
das ist die art und die berühmteste
schied oder alpen und für jeden
einzelnen der gruppe ein traum der sich
nun erfüllt
und
[Musik]
die route ist gespickt mit langen
aufstiegen mit fell und china und
steinkohle dino mit steigeisen zu
bewältigen sind
diesen fakten
miranda miranda und die severin und
franz machen so geschafft und erreicht
mit mir die wenigsten haben große touren
erfahrung bis auf yolanda di heute eine
seilschaft übernimmt
clooney als nur vorbehalten
wasser ohne chlor verschafft aber die
märkte sowie biblis sieht das sehr gern
mal ganz klar vor ihnen liegt das 200
meter steile cooler über den goldener
grund louis die heutige schlüsselstelle
sie sind als gruppe alleine unterwegs
sind der riesigen gletscherlandschaft
garten
das
auch gemacht werden kann der hang ist
steil furchteinflößend für jene die
nicht gewohnt sind mit steigeisen zu
gehen
heute ist david als bergführer besonders
gefragt
er hat die weniger erfahrenen berggänger
am seil
wie peter den heilpädagogen
der mutig werden will oder kamen die im
andenken an ihre verstorbene mutter auf
der tour mit dabei ist
moment
nach dem ausfall des bergführers bruno
jelk ist es ac turin leiterin yolanda
heute eingesprungen und führt die zweite
seilschaft mit fränzi und cb hin
langsam arbeitet sich die gruppe im wind
hoch
das seil soll einen absturz verhindern
3par für die administration
einziger fels
der mittdreißiger fels
doch erst hoch
der grund es gibt nicht nach
di luca scassa bald praktisch ja dann
sind eine schwierigkeit ist und ich
jetzt schon hier aufeinander los wir
kommen
ruhig und gelassen hat yolanda ihre
seilschaft durch die steile flanke
geführt steigeisen beck was nun folgt
ist eine lange abfahrt
[Musik]
dann endlich das worauf sich die
skirennfahrerinnen am meisten gefreut
haben alle abfahrt
bergführer david phasen fährt mit
dominik fränzi und souverän vorneweg
[Musik]
der weg auf dem gletscher muss gut
gewählt werden
[Musik]
bergführer ralf weber der auch für die
sicherheit des fernsehteams zuständig
ist folgt mit jolanda unter zweiter
gruppe
[Musik]
die schnee bedeckte fläche des
gletschers ist tückisch
immer wieder tauchen unvermittelt
riesige offene spalten auf die für die
gruppe schwer einsehbar sind
du glaubst 2000
[Musik]
rund eine stunde hat die abfahrt von
über 3.000 metern bis ins tal nach la
folie auf fast 1600 metern gedauert
auch der 72 jährige paul der die ortrud
schon vor 50 jahren gemacht hat hat es
geschafft er yolanda hilft vor einer
stunde noch waren sie im sturm in fels
und eis geklettert größer könnte der
gegensatz nicht sein aber es wurden als
hätte er bis jetzt noch gas oder aber
der am liebsten liebsten wieder abbrach
und henker oder mit das natürlich wissen
wir dass du bist immer schon aber ich es
mir sehr spanier goldige aber jetzt auch
besser so vorgestellt oder oder welche
server abend desto weniger streng oder
strenger und die passage mit abseilen
also das gar nicht erwartet dass es geht
beim orden heimischer vorgestellt aber
es ist möglich relativ stark sie also
wenn drei mal hinter sie vorsichtig
macht dennoch paul hat schon sofort
stellt oder er 50 jahre mal gemacht und
schultern kann ja einzig als auch die
abfolge ist zudem schafften immer
geändert was ich ja ja ja aber gütig auf
dem video ist wirklich gut
da waren ja aber die regierungen ja ja
ja das haben wir schon bei 53 jährige
gut schlafen
die zivilisation wie es also das gut
das freut mich
[Musik]
sie sind im spiel
jolanda ist seit drei jahren
alleinerziehende mutter zweier buben und
war in all dieser zeit noch nie länger
von ihm getrennt
weiter geht die tour per bus nach
verbier dann mit der bahn ins skigebiet
von morpho zur morf erhöhte auf 2.457
metern
die hütte steht mitten im skigebiet und
ist mit allem komfort ausgestattet
[Musik]
seit aufzutanken und kräfte zu sammeln
für die nächsten tage
du bist klappt da sie haben kein platz
mehr für mich wie papier folien nach
drei tagen eine erste dusche
auch internet empfang gehört zum service
der hütte ich muss lange ob ich der oper
empfang auf dem ipad zeit zu entspannen
oder wie im fall von dominique gisin und
fränzi aufdenblatten auf ihre beziehung
als weltcup pfarrerinnen und
konkurrentinnen zurückzublicken jetzt
wirklich eine freundschaft und die
andere die sich halt nicht so dass ich
halt noch wenig kontakt will in wetzlar
gekonnt gespielt und jetzt in streit
geraten
es klemmt die meine hand erforderlicher
burgring
das ist dieses mal der konkurrenzdruck
waren an welche bank oder miliz weil ich
zum beispiel extrem geschätzt dass wir
ordentlich mal geteilt oder obwohl das
wäre ein klick konkurrenz sowohl es wird
nicht besser transics sie wiederkommen
aber sehr professionell
beide profitieren und der maske und und
ich meine neugier olympiasieger wurde
und ich rate zu ändern immer keine
fahrscheine für den topf roman taxi aber
noch genauer städtischen alltag wirklich
voll
ich spiele ja die zerstört und das hilft
mit dem monster wenn systems können oder
wollen erklärt dass er gleich von
schwänzen ist wünsche ich mir dass franz
jetzt das seiten bedeutet mir das
natürlich sehr viel will sie weiß ganz
genau was leicht ist und das ist schon
mal abend das mit dem
ja
[Musik]
die gruppe wächst durch die
herausforderung der rote immer mehr zu
einem team zusammen haben in den bergen
planen sie einander mit persönlichen
hochs und tiefs kennen
[Musik]
nur einer fehlt bergführer bruno jelk
der die gruppe vor einem tag aus
gesundheitlichen gründen verlassen
musste und für den jolanthe heute
eingesprungen ist dass wir jetzt das
sehe diesen relativ große gruppe normale
wie es geht und wie fliegt durch das eeg
die zimmer einfach so entscheiden das
tor auf mit luft
das wollen wir möglichkeiten her fixe
xxl länger die tu am start
die tour beginnt auf der bahn mord vor
ein erster aufstieg auf den goldenen
schuh
es folgt die rosa blau auf über 3000
meter und danach eine lange lauf passage
am lack die dies bis zur bande dies mit
neun stunden 17 kilometern und 1800
metern aufstieg ist es die längste
etappe der wagen sieht das auch hinter
die lang lang lang lang lang als
zückerchen gibt noch eine runde
champions league
die spiele geholt haben also es geht
ordentlich
[Musik]
tagwacht ist um vier uhr
die erste etappe startet auf der
vereisten piste des skigebietes
[Applaus]
die wettervorhersage für heute ist gut
doch in den nächsten tagen kündigt sich
eine schlechtwetterfront an inntal
sammelt sich die feuchtigkeit in den
wolken erste blessuren machen sich
bemerkbar
[Musik]
der welt genießt er ohne natürlich gutes
los und jetzt da schon immer sie ist
david gibt peter wertvolle tipps wie er
heute kräfte sparen kann
es ist der vierte tag auf der hut über
24 stunden mit tourenskis und steiger
heißen hat die gruppe bereits in den
beinen
[Musik]
jeder kämpft für sich und versucht
seinen eigenen rhythmus zu finden
dennoch liegt die hälfte der hut vor ihm
[Musik]
das passierte vorne mitreden hier wie
chrysler wieder mitmachen
der 72 jährige paul hat seine chance an
den bergführer abgegeben
umso willkommener die pause für alle auf
dem goldenen schuh so severin der
ehemalige zehnkämpfer entspannt wie auch
fränzi die ex spitzensportlerin bin ich
froh um die überbleibsel mit
jetzt bin ich richtig so amon ins mikro
und sich irgendwie also automatisch
koffer und heute morgen um das warum
jahre reflektierte manchester sicheren
an ich glaube will man nicht schön
hinteren angriffe ich sondern so benannt
und nehmer grüßt während vorne und aber
das ist vermutlich bin natürlich sich
und schon einmal gefragt was auch jetzt
spüre ich war jetzt schon am aufschlagen
um einfach recht wird nach der tat was
hat sich da zusammen haben ja aber die
zähne doch die ja ich bin froh wenn
jetzt der overlord ehrlich gesagt jetzt
mal noch nicht nur an einem krieg hat
die verfehlungen sind schnell gegangen
ist das kann ich gar nicht so ich bin
nicht so einfach als auch erkannt hast
du das gar nicht
[Musik]
der rucksack mit allem material wiegt
rund zehn kilo das gepäck trägt wieder
selber von hütte zu hütte
im nebel wird auch die orientierung
immer schwieriger
[Musik]
bergführer david ist gefordert hier
da kann selbst eine wache in china
lassen
der hauptbau gemacht
vor rund drei stunden ist die gruppe in
der hütte gestartet
[Musik]
david drückt aufs tempo
am nachmittag wird es wieder heiß hinter
der bergkette ist der lack daddys der
direkt in der lawinen zone liegt und
nach dem schneereichen wintern us
lawinen thrun
[Musik]
ja da schnell überrascht dezibel tags es
jetzt auch noch da oder große flasche
das spitzer vormachen
um im zeitplan zu bleiben will david den
gipfel der loser branche zwei stunden
erreicht haben
[Musik]
genauso shimano sowie potenziale stecken
sie nach möglichkeit auf dem velo
nearest konnte ja genau
es geht durch die besseren das habe ich
am 6
daraus ergibt sich im kopf plötzlich
tauchten fragen auf so wie im urlaub was
mache ich eigentlich die frage nach dem
sinn
und dann hat ein hofer gut
durchtrainierte sportler irgendwo
einfach möglich schwarzen aber trauer
und ich danke eigentlich schöne mit
schwarzem organe befällt man dann
wirklich zu fuß und dann falls aufdrehen
kopf war wer bin ich was mache ich da
überhaupt und kirche die gruppe oder
gehörig nötige gruppen und wieso mag ich
nicht mit schwarzer und dann fang zur
ausbeutung kann ich das kann ich
wahrscheinlich noch genommen werden und
dann muss ich das bewusst wie der
abschnitt 30 party ist logisch aber es
ist so schön und und dann wieder und man
könnte ich stimme wieder und dann heißt
es wieder ab und die denn jetzt
[Musik]
laufen nur auf
alleine mit sich der natur und seinen
gedanken
stundenlang gleichen trott keine
ablenkung nichts
[Musik]
so bewegen dass wir das zunächst der
ärger luft machen
also wird die kluft sache die arbeit
dass sie vorn da nicht wieder auf ich
bin ich dass ich hier so team auf dem
quad und immer das gefühl da geht immer
besser mit der höchsten aktivieren und
sache und gerade hier nach
ja ich sage jetzt kommt mit großen
schritten um heimbringt klagen wir sind
der brauwelt befahren wird sich um die
tage darauf folgte die promotion fragt
sich ist ja wunderschön mit bärbel
richter dies entscheiden
immer näher kommen sie der rosa blogs
und ihrem ziel zermatt wie sie wie sie
hoch mit hermine als wodka warum
vielleicht sogar dass der einzige carla
maria war da rufen aber hier zerstörte
visier der name fahrerprofil ich zeit
fordert wollen sie sich an die großen
studios dann brauch' jetzt aber das
schafft hat sich guttenberg für gott die
motivatoren es wird noch liegen aber
über zwei tage vor ihnen bevor sie das
matterhorn erreichen
der weg dahin führt über die besteigung
der rosa blau david klettert mit der
stärkeren gruppe am seil vorgang
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erfolg mit der zweiten gruppe paul peter
und carmen yolanda sicher zuhinterst
[Musik]
mit links
sechs leier
[Musik]
und dann nach über fünf stunden recht
mit seinem team den höchsten punkt des
tages die rosa branche
[Musik]
taxi
so wachse dank wird kein freund von mir
dass ich jetzt das schon witz und auch
ralph alt mit paul peter und carmen am
sei das superleichte gemacht
ideal
euphorie aber auch das wissen dass der
heutige tag noch lange nicht zu ende ist
und der härteste teil noch bevorsteht
und das sehen sie in der nächsten folge
carmens blasen werden zum problem denn
es ist noch weit
auch mal wieder jemanden
[Musik]
schwitzen und kämpft in der hitze bis
zur cabane dies
paul mit seinen 72 jahren wird zum held
dominique gisin hat eine neue formel
entdeckt stürmischer aufstieg auf die
linie der roller bevor die
schlechtwetterfront ein bericht in der
zwei tage später sieben menschen ums
leben kommen
und ein letztes zusammenrücken im biwak
punkte dies und mehr in der letzten
folge von abenteuer alpen die spur des
lebens
[Musik]
abenteuer alpen wurde ihnen präsentiert
von ikea hopi der geschmack der schweiz
seit 11 115
[Musik]